- Okay, okay.
- Let's see what we got here.
- "Hotline Bling."
- Ooh, "Hotline Bling" by Drake
to the music
of Foreigner "Cold As Ice."
- All right. I got this.
- Come on, partner.
- I feel like you should have
gotten this one.
All right, band,
you got this, Adam?
- All right. I'm ready.
- Let's try right here.
- Oh, my god, I'm so excited.
- Here we go.
- ♪ You used to call me on my
♪ You, you, you, you used
to call me on my cell phone ♪
- Oh, he's great.
- ♪ Late night when you
need my love ♪
♪ Call me on my cell phone
- Yeah!
♪ Late night when you need
my love ♪
♪ And I know when
that hotline bling ♪
♪ That can only mean
one thing ♪
♪ Ever since I left the city,
you ♪
♪ Got a reputation for yourself
now ♪
♪ Everybody knows
and I feel left out ♪
♪ Girl you got me down,
you got me stressed out ♪
♪ 'Cause ever since
I left the city, you ♪
♪ Started wearing less
and goin' out more ♪
♪ Glasses of champagne out
on the dance floor ♪
♪ Hangin' with some girls
I've never seen before ♪
♪ Yeah
♪ You used to call me
on my cell phone ♪
- Yes!
That was amazing!
- Hey!
- Yeah!
- That was amazing!
- That is
an actual standing ovation.
That was
a real standing ovation!
- That's
a good partner there.
We're a wedding.
- Hey, wait.